thank you nate today is national barbie
day and our next guest knows a thing or
two about barbies and actually all toys
let's welcome back to the show steve
johnson from rogue toys hey steve how's
it going
how you doing jc thanks for having me so
how did barbie get her start
well you know what's funny is uh ruth
handler the creator of
barbie basically took a trip got
influenced by some barbies
and uh blythe dolls really and she was
influenced to make barbie and she
created the barbie doll
as we know it today i see you've got
some barbies there next to you how has
barbie changed through the years and
what do you have with you there today
well you know okay so this is a ponytail
number four and this is one of the first
original barbies this is from 1960 and
then
i have a color change where
you can actually color change your hair
and this would be into the 70s
and what you'll notice is that over the
years barbie had things like
bendable knees they made twist and turn
waste they've done a lot of things to
really articulate
the posability of the doll to where even
when you get into the
the stuff from the 90s and the 2000s you
started getting a ton of really great
accessories like you see here with the
the uh the rising star barbie and uh
you know they they've really taken a lot
of time like barbie was a
a doll that is a fashion doll and
because she was a fashion doll
she is one of those dolls that was
influenced by what was happening during
the time period so in the 70s the bell
bottoms and stuff like that was
available to barbie
you know swimsuits have always been huge
for her uh
and so you know as styles have changed
so has barbie barbie's evolved with them
so if someone's watching right now and
they have a collection
is it a barbie collection worth any
money right now
well you know barbie collections can be
valuable now we see a lot of people
bring them from like the 90s and the
2000s
sometimes there's a lot of those that
are out there and available and not real
valuable
there are certain pieces though so what
you can always do you think you got
something of value
bring it in on it on into us let us take
a look at it see if it's something that
we might be able to
turn into some cash for you but we're
always looking for barbie collections
because uh there's always going to be a
barbie collector out there
okay now what about barbie's accessories
i remember my sister she had she had the
barbie house growing up and she loved
she played with that thing every single
day
until i took my he-man's and he-man
would come crashing down he man would
take over the barbie house
if someone has an accessory like the
barbie house i remember she had a
corvette
are those accessories worth any money
some of them can be
uh for example the barbie mansions are
all very desirable
very higher ticket value items in fact
we have one at the west las vegas store
and the the accessories just like her
clothing
have really over time evolved her cars
have changed she went from the corvette
to the volkswagen bug
she's you know had motor homes she's had
a multitude of apartments
stage sets i mean you name it she's
involved she's involved steve i got
less than 15 seconds i do want to jump
in because real quick you have a swap
meet
happening this saturday how do people
get in touch with you in the swap meet
this saturday
yes so you can visit roguetoys.com or
visit us on facebook instagram or
twitter
roguetoys our toy swap in sales from 10
a.m to 2 p.m we have vendors with all
kinds of nerdy goods craps toys and
games
steve always great having you on thanks
for joining us we appreciate it and
mercedes we'll send it over to you